these large-scale wall paintings tell
the stories of people and relationships
and they brighten up even the most drab
of places
they all carry the signature of one
woman Alicia Pasquini she's one of the
few female stars on the International
street art scene
her work has long been on display in
galleries but she prefers to paint on
walls a wall is not something more than
a convent
a wall has a story colors people living
around and working in my studio owner
canvas I gave me no inspirations to work
on something of a radius story like a
wall or recycled material that's making
me feel more inspired Pasquini sprays
and brushes masterpieces on two walls
all over the world but most of her work
can be found here on the streets of her
home city Rome the artist also finds her
models on the streets just people and
their day-to-day lives she captures
these fleeting moments in her sketchbook
what is moving me more is the things
that will not change in 50 years you
know what I mean
something as universal and in this way
every time I'm traveling around I have
the confirmation that the feelings are
not changing from you know most called
to Singapore to Sydney the artist has a
studio in the artist district of San
Lorenzo where she creates paintings
illustrations and commissioned works she
discovered her passion for graffiti
while studying classical art it was also
a way of protesting against the elitist
art scene I was upset because as a young
student most of the time I was going to
see an exhibition I was feeling stupid
because I was not understanding it's not
about reading from the stomach something
about brain and wanting to the street as
a reaction of all these and because I
was likely to paint since I was a little
girl
whether it's a wall or a canvas people
and relationships are at the heart of
all her work cus Queenie enjoys painting
women the most depicting how they really
are without stereotypes
parents and society propose us character
it's already done we have to respect
this character so we have to be kind and
not so much Korea's not running around
too much and we know it's why all the
girls are curious and irreverent and you
know during her projects called
under layers into the wall Alisha
Pasquini worked with a photographer to
explore the new world of 3d street art
she created these model walls in
preparation to transform a B dimensional
paint in a 3d F in a 3d project I had to
divide on many many levels these are
only four but in reality were seven plus
of background by wearing 3d glasses
viewers could immerse themselves in the
art at this exhibition in Rome earlier
this year
this direct contact with the audience
motivates the artist to carry on
painting in public spaces each one of us
is sitting in a different way and this
exchange was happening in the street the
people telling what they were feeling
explaining to the others this idea of
exchange also inspired her work at a
refugee shelter in Rome
earlier this year Pasquini transformed
the stories of young migrants into wall
art the artist has very modest
aspirations for her work
I think at the end the history of
humanity is full of art is the history
of human being so we need these can
change the war became making a little
Heather you know so and Alicia Pasquini
does just that
making the world that little bit better
wall by wall